I think bouncing academics and athletics
really takes discipline and also a
realistic understanding of what you can
accomplish I know that I can handle a
few things on my plate at once so that's
how I was able to you know take on
athletics and also do a lot of other
things on campus I think the thing that
makes Deb excel is her motivation as
well as their time management skills
she's very motivated and what she's
trying to do so because of her time
management skills she's learned how to
really work the system in the best way
that it can be so I'm a sprinter and a
jumper I compete in anything from the
100-meter dash 200 meter dash or 400
meter dash and I also long jump I was
drawn to CMU for its emphasis in
research and technology I wanted to come
to a place where I could continue my
track career in college as well as have
a strong emphasis in my school work and
study biology Deb has been a huge impact
player for the last three years the
moment she stepped on campus we knew
that she was going to excel for it I try
to inspire and mentor the younger
athletes on the team by coming to
practice every day and having a good
attitude about the workouts when I come
into practice I kind of have a mindset
that I'm ready to lead the workout to
push those times to hit the intervals I
try to do that through examples so by
leading the workouts on my team Carnegie
Mellon does a really good job at
supporting their student athletes the
benefit of competing in Division three
sports is that you're a student first
and foremost so I've definitely been
able to do that here at Carnegie Mellon